schneiden sie sich besser an denn es
erwarten sie haar sträubende aufnahmen
ob reingefahren oder platt gemacht
haarscharf vorbei oder mittenrein
kleine kameras auf dem armaturenbrett
sogenannte des camps zeichnen gnadenlos
alles auf
in vielen ländern boomt der markt für
base camps die aufnahmen sollen bei
unfällen als beweismittel dienen und vor
betrügern schützen die abkassieren
wollen
kein wunder also dass immer mehr
verblüffende videoclips im umlauf sind
halten sie sich gut fest wir starten
unsere reise um die welt mit bildern die
ihnen garantiert den atem rauben werden
los geht's
das sind die spektakulärsten des camps
und keine sorge
niemand wird hier ernsthaft verletzt
auch wenn es manchmal knapp wird
richtig knapp heute dabei
rücksichtsloses fahren mit
katastrophalen konsequenzen
[Applaus]
karambolagen bei schnee und eis
[Musik]
und der her
mir doch egal
das wird abgefahren
fahrt vorsichtig und beachte die regeln
wie oft haben sie hinterm steuer schon
gedacht was für ein idiot so wie dieser
hier oder dieser vorsicht umsicht und
rücksicht machen einen guten fahrer aus
[Musik]
leider sind viele auf den straßen
unterwegs die nichts davon mitbringen
aber sehen sie selbst
ein plastisches beispiel dieser
verstrahlte lkw-fahrer der einfach so
bei knallrot über die kreuzung rast
für diesen rettungswagen geht es nicht
so glimpflich aus auch wenn er über rote
ampeln fahren darf sollte die sicherheit
vorfahrt haben
der zusammenstoß mit diesem riesigen lkw
sieht nicht danach aus aber
glücklicherweise wurde niemand ernstlich
verletzt achtung gut aufpassen
auf den ersten blick sieht es so aus als
sei der plötzliche spurwechsel schuld am
unfall doch was steckt denn da in der
taschentuch schachtel
das handy des fahrers so was die polizei
kann ihm schließlich nachweisen dass er
es während des unfalls benutzt hatte
seine hand spiegelt sich nämlich in der
windschutzscheibe auf frischer tat
ertappt beide fahrer werden bestraft
manchmal beschützt uns der
armaturenbrett buddha
manchmal auch nicht
ein riskantes überholmanöver
und schon liegt man auf der seite und
guckt blöd aus der wäsche
was passiert wenn etwas sehr schweres
jahr quasi unverrückbares mit vier
unwiderstehlicher kraft getroffen wird
sowas
[Musik]
ein crash der giganten das nennt man mal
eine wirklich schwere fehlentscheidung
woran man einen betrunkenen fahrer
erkennt naja er fährt zb ungefähr so
wie praktisch da ist er seine bank nein
es gibt leider keinen drive in schalter
die polizei lässt ihn pusten und stellt
fest so viele promille gehe in das
gefängnis begib dich direkt dorthin gehe
nicht über los ziehen nicht 4000 euro
ein
zement laster sind keine rennwagen man
kann damit nicht so gut schnell um die
kurve fahren das sieht man hier sehr
schön
der lkw fährt über rot muss einem auto
ausweichen und gerät außer kontrolle
[Musik]
schneeflöckchen weißröckchen
im schnee kann man richtig viel spaß
haben das gilt für den garten oder die
rodelbahn aber nicht so sehr für die
autobahn fahren bei schnee und eis ist
gefährlich man hat weniger grip und
schlechtere sicht
frühmorgens in den schulbus zu steigen
ist schon nervig wenn dann noch schnee
und ein steiler berg dazu kommen wird's
richtig nerven aufreibend
[Musik]
mein gott der bus hat keine schneeketten
der liebe gott kann doch nichts dafür
allradantrieb bringt wenig wenn man
nicht auto fahren kann
[Applaus]
schönes auto aber wenn sie so
weitermachen nicht mehr lange
was für eine belastung ein langer harter
kalter winter sein kann zeigt dieser
baum
das war einfach zu viel schnee
er wird um wie ein betrunkener der
umfeld wie ein baum
[Musik]
der kanadische sommer die kanadier
lieben zelten grillen am strand und
spontaner offroad touren
wasser auf die erde auf
wir bleiben im sonnigen kanada wo
rettungshelfer mit schneemobilen
liegengebliebene autofahrer versorgen
sie bringen essen benzin und decken und
vergessen regel nummer eins
[Musik]
nicht mit dem schneemobilen mitten auf
der straße halten das resultat ein
kaputter arm und zwei kaputte
schneemobile
sind wir auf dem planeten rot möglich
nur die erde mit einer straße die sich
als rodelbahn verkleidet hat
was tun wenn man nichts sieht wo es
weitergeht
erst mal anhalten und die lage sondieren
[Musik]
und siehe da man ist nicht der einzige
wer im winter fährt sollte bei schnee
und eis lenken und bremsen können der
bremsweg kann locker viermal länger sein
das kann dann auch mal daneben gehen
[Musik]
dann bringt man sich am besten in
sicherheit und beobachtet das geschehen
aus der entfernung
kuleschow hat jemand popcorn
runter von der straße
[Musik]
das zusammenleben von fahrzeugen und
fußgängern ist nicht immer völlig
unproblematisch
augen auf beim überqueren der straße
manche rennen einfach drauf los
und weil insgesamt immer mehr menschen
über die straße gehen
[Musik]
gibt es dabei auch immer mehr unfälle
die winter in moskau sind hart aber die
menschen sind hertha
voll
hartmann mehrere
googeln sie mal nervigste person der
welt oder gucken sie einfach mal hier ja
es geht um dich du penner
deine 15 sekunden ruhm applaus applaus
man sieht sofort dieser mann ist
ausgeglichen kontrolliert und
stocknüchtern
die welt gehört die riege der ganz
allein
was in vegas passiert bleibt in vegas
außer die per scan läuft
beim überqueren der straße sind augen
und buchen gefragt
doch mit kopfhörern im ohr oder einem
handy vor der nase wird das schwierig
dieser typ ist so cool den look der
mopedfahrer wenig dafür gibt es einen
blauen fleck
in ermangelung eines sportplatzes
entscheiden sich diese kits für eine
dreispurige straße
[Musik]
egal wie schnell wir seit ein auto ist
auf jeden fall noch schneller
schnell weg sonst endet die als you say
[Musik]
no
reason für autofahrer
ja genau mädel über dich spreche ich
hier gerade
[Musik]
ein dreistes manöver von einem nervigen
fußgänger sorgt kurz für verwirrung bei
diesem radfahrer
[Musik]
witzig witzig drei meter 70
wer auf straßenbahnschienen parkt muss
sich nicht wundern wenn andere die sache
in die hand nehmen
während die besitzerin ihrer einkäufe
erledigt können sich diese trambahn
passagiere um ihr auto sie kriegt einen
dicken strafzettel und zum trost mehr
likes auf facebook als eine katze die
klavier spielt
[Musik]
auch wenn das inszeniert wird der moped
fahrer und sein sozius hatten wirklich
nur pech
[Musik]
im gegensatz zu diesem aufwendigen
stammt aus einem hollywood blockbuster
[Musik]
alles einsteigen
in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln können
wir entspannen eine runde schlafen oder
in einem buch schmökern dafür müssen wir
unsere sicherheit anderen anvertrauen
noch dazu gibt es keine gurte dass
campos schief gehen
wer gewinnt der außer kontrolle geratene
minivan oder der bus die antwort
keiner wie durch ein wunder wird niemand
ernsthaft verletzt
dieser ältere herr ist sauer auf den
busfahrer
weil der an seiner haltestelle
vorbeigefahren ist wirft er eine
handgranate ich hab wirklich eine
handgranate der zünder explodiert die
granate selber glücklicherweise nicht er
wird verhaftet und fährt in der nächsten
zeit gar nicht mehr bus
[Musik]
noch ein beispiel dafür was passieren
kann wenn der busfahrer nicht anhält
obwohl der bus recht flott auf der
autobahn unterwegs ist will dieser
fahrgast unbedingt aussteigen und
tatsächlich springt er aus dem fahrenden
bus
hätte er nicht bis zur nächsten
haltestelle warten können
[Musik]
immer wieder machen betrunkene
randalierer busfahrern das leben schwer
diese hier sind besonders reizen der
exemplare der fahrer fährt tapfer weiter
als diese männer zuerst seine frisur
ruinieren und ihn danach in den
schwitzkasten nehmen der fahrer geht
schließlich zu boden und der bus landet
auf dem bürgersteig
dieser fahrer dagegen ist selber schuld
wie die aufnahmen beweisen er schaut
lieber aufs handy als auf die straße und
rammte ein lkw vor ihm
[Musik]
die fahrgäste kamen mit leichten
verletzungen und dem schrecken davon den
bus kann man wegschmeißen aber immerhin
der fahrer hat einen neuen rekord bei
candy crash aufgestellt
weiß doch jeder dass man den busfahrer
nicht während der fahrt ansprechen der
herr quatscht gerade mit drei kumpels
die auch noch im gang rumsitzen 'was
passiert wenn keiner auf die straße
guckt
[Musik]
also die kumpels lieber erst nach
feierabend treffen
und jetzt was richtig herzerwärmendes
diese hochschwangere dame bereichert den
bus gleich um einen weiteren fahrgast
die anderen fahrgäste machen es ihr so
bequem wie möglich und der busfahrer
fährt ganz vorsichtig zum krankenhaus
dort kommen hebamme und
krankenschwestern an bord und das baby
wird entbunden
[Musik]
wir können vermelden mutter und kind
sind wohlauf
[Musik]
achtung angeber
seit wir menschen fahrbare untersätze
erfunden haben stellen wir die
verrücktesten sachen damit an und
natürlich sind wir alle ausgezeichnete
fahrer wie schön dass es jetzt auch des
camps gibt die das alles für die
nachwelt festhalten
motorradfahrer haben so viel spaß auf
zwei rädern oder eine
oder gar kann
[Musik]
auch beim release cool aussehen das ist
wirklich gefährlich bitte nicht auf
öffentlichen straßen üben
und auch nicht mit fahrrädern
diese jungs haben es drauf ein willi auf
einem gefrorenen see respekt
das hier ist auch zirkusreif
aber vor allem ist es verboten und sehr
gefährlich was das ganze noch schlimmer
macht
hinter ihm fährt seine stolze mutter
vielleicht liegt der wahnsinn in der
familie
zum nächsten zirkuskünstler
ohne netz und doppelten boden
weiter geht's mit spezialisten auf vier
rädern dieser hier kannte sogar james
bond noch etwas beibringen beim
einparken
jetzt nur noch dank raus handbremse
ziehen motor abstellen und tief ausatmen
[Musik]
dieses auto ist zwar falsch rum auf der
straße fährt aber immerhin in die
richtige richtung nämlich rückwärts und
das mit fast 100 sachen
auch nicht schlecht
[Musik]
er soll nur die steilwand hochfahren und
einen rückwärtssalto machen kinder
spielen
[Applaus]
hey das solltest du beruflich machen
autos die über eine klappbrücke fahren
die gerade auf geht kennen wir aus dem
kino er hier anscheinend auch
abgehakt jetzt noch eine verfolgungsjagd
bitte wir bleiben beim kino dieser wenn
probiert den guten alten fahr auf zwei
rädern stammt das sieht gut aus bis auf
den schluss
[Musik]
übrigens so fährt man auf zwei raedern
was für ein überaus eleganten minibagger
[Musik]
kinderleben es im schnee zu spielen auch
große kinder können viel spaß haben auf
einem verschneiten parkplatz
aber ein surfstick echt jetzt
wer nicht in den knast will muss sauber
bleiben
jetzt wird es kriminell aber damit
durchzukommen wird zunehmend schwieriger
immer mehr polizisten sind auf den
straßen unterwegs und fast überall sind
kameras die alles aufnehmen auf
überzeugende ausreden zu kommen ist dann
gar nicht so leicht
viel zu oft werden menschen durch
betrunkene autofahrer verletzt
aufmerksamkeit reaktionsvermögen und
koordination sind unter alkohol stark
beeinträchtigt ohne das auto neben ihm
zu bemerken driftet der fahrer auf die
andere spur
dann gibt er gas und merkt nicht dass
die polizei hinter ihm fährt
[Musik]
schließlich krachte er in eine
absperrung
den rest übernehmen die cops
dieser betrunkene fahrer dreht völlig
durch als er die polizisten bemerkte
bei seiner gefährlichen wende überfährt
er fast einen moped und einem
fahrradfahrer die beamten wollen den
mann aufhalten aber der gibt einfach gas
der fluchtversuch endet dramatisch
zum glück bleibt der polizist unverletzt
und der mann landet im gefängnis
in australien testet dieser mann wie
schnell er von 0 auf 100 ist in einer
geschlossenen ortschaft
die verkehrspolizei hat auf ein genie
wie ihn schon gewartet sehr zur freude
der jungs hinter ihm
[Musik]
sie haben
ja wirklich fantastisch
[Musik]
absolut klasse sache
radarfallen reduzieren die zahl der
verkehrsunfälle deutlich
trotzdem gibt es leute die sie lieber
los wären wählt dieser lkw fahrer mit
einem hammer will er die kamera
ausschalten
dumm dass sie ihn bei der aktion film
er wird später festgenommen und
verurteilt
und hier was fürs guinness-buch der
rekorde
wie viele menschen passen in ein auto
die polizei hält diesen wenn an
alle passagiere müssen aussteigen
das dauert denn es sind 51 richtig 51 in
einem sechssitzer
tatsächlich rekordverdächtig
[Musik]
wenn man sich nicht gut fühlt sollte man
sich lieber nicht ans steuer setzen wenn
man am tropf hängt zum beispiel
dieser mann hat sich selbst vorzeitig
aus dem krankenhaus entlassen und hält
sich für fahrtüchtig die polizei sieht
das anders das ist echt sowas von krank
zum schluss noch ein paar wirklich
elegante mangelware bitte nicht
nachmachen
[Musik]
[Applaus]